>> GRANDMA MIGHT PASS OUT.
>> FOR KICKS OFF WITH THE
SPEAKER, AMY MITCHELL WHO
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO WORK THAT
MIKE.
>> SOMETIMES I WISH -- AND THAT
I COULD STAY AT THIS SCHOOL.
>> FOLLOWED BY VALEDICTORIAN
OLIVER KLINE.
THE SMARTEST KID IN CLASS GIVING
THE WORLD'S SALTIEST SPEECH.
>> SOME OF US WERE CONSIDERED
COOL OR POPULAR AND GIRLS DIDN'T
NOTICE ME, BUT IN A FEW YEAR,
BOY OH, BOY THINGS ARE GOING TO
CHANGE AND YOU WISH YOU HAD
GOTTEN ME.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE CLASS OF
2018.
>> BITTER MUCH?
>> I DIDN'T THINK SO.
IT'S TIME FOR THE MAIN EVENT.
HANDING OUT DIPLOMAS.
ALL YOUR FAVORITES WILL BE THERE
WITH GRADS WITH UNFORTUNATE
NAMES AND ASHLEY BRANDT WHO IS
MAKING A CONFUSED POLITICAL
STATEMENT.
>> GET YOUR LAWS OFF MY UTERUS
AND SAVE THE HONEY BEES.
>> AND HOW ABOUT MATT JONES WHO
HAS BEEN TELLING EVERYONE HE IS
GOING TO DO A BACKHAND SPRING
AND BAILS AT THE LAST MINUTE.
AND WHEN VISIBY PREGNANT SENIOR
COURTNEY KING TAKE THE STAGE,
WATCH THAT HIT THE PARENT
SECTION LIKE AN ATOMIC BOMB.
>> WHO'S THE FATHER.
>> THE PRINCIPAL MISPRONOUNCES
THE INDIAN KID'S LAST NAME.
>> AND OF COURSE -- IS IT A BOY
OR A GIRL?
>> AND IT'S TIME FOR DADS WITH
iPADS AND NO ONE KNOWS WHICH
PHONE TO LOOK AT.
SECRETS WILL BE REVEALED LIKE
WHEN YOU REALIZE THE PARENTS ARE
LIKE NORMAL?
>> HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> AND THEN LOOK, THERE IS A
SENIOR HAVING DRAMA WITH HIS
GIRLFRIEND WHO'S A SOPHOMORE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DATE COLLEGE
GIRLS MUCH WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BREAK UP, OKAY?
>> YEAH THEY WILL.
>> A DAY TO REMEMBER, BUT THE
ONLY THING EVERYTHING WILL
REMEMBER IS WHEN THE PRINCIPAL
FELL OFF THE STAGE.
>> DEFINE THE TERM GRADUATE.
>> THE JAMES MADISON HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION.
YOUR GRANDMA FLEW IN FOR THIS.